what we're seeing in beijing here is
concern that chinese authorities may not
be able to get covet cases under control
in the chinese capital things have
actually been relatively normal for most
of the past two years but now with the
omicron variant spreading so quickly
across china and threatening the capital
the mood has changed
and i'm now here at a supermarket in
beijing where
they've really been stocking up quickly
to make sure that shelves are full of
fruits vegetables meats and other goods
and over the weekend we saw a lot of
panic buying here as people were
stockpiling and hoarding
goods people in beijing were looking at
shanghai and the lock down there that
has persisted for
more than a month already and worried
about their own supplies of vegetables
and so people have been basically
filling their shopping baskets with as
much as they could get
if we do get cases spreading in china
that is going to threaten the economy
for the global economy too of course
china is the world's second largest
economy this is a country that is deeply
tied to the west it may have to keep its
borders closed for many more months to
come perhaps even years and that's going
to have an impact both on expatriates
and multinationals doing business in
china as well as trading partners of
china so the question is really how much
china is going to be able to do to prop
up its economy this year a year in which
stability is going to be paramount as xi
jinping the leader seeks to secure a
third term in power